Aiden Mohammed Noor is a firewood Trader
in dadab town it's home to thousands of
Somali refugees who have escaped
conflict and drought most rely on
firewood and charcoal for warmth and
cooking
nor a canyon says he has to travel
farther to look for acacia trees which
are endangered species before we used to
work for a short time to find the trees
now we have to walk for five days to
find anything that can make us enough
money the trees are getting scarce
trees and party grasslands have long
existed in this region but now they have
all but disappeared exposing the area to
sandstorms and blistering Heats people
here rely on firewood for their cooking
needs we have been talking to sellers
who say they have to go far to look for
trees to cut but they also know the harm
caused by cutting down trees but they
say this is their livelihoods
droughts have become more frequent in
recent years
five rainy seasons have failed in the
Horn of Africa millions of people are on
the brink of starvation the number of
people living in dadab and other arid
areas is growing rapidly and resources
are stretched
climate change is also making life worse
for many Kenya is ahead of many other
countries in working to safeguard the
environment but honestly say more needs
to be done there is a difference with
actions that are happening as pockets
as compared to happening at scale
and touching the lives of many people
and the argument is can we bring those
pockets of successes to scale not
necessarily only in Horn of Africa but
we need to graduate from policy to
action
all his life he says if the environment
continues to deteriorate he can see his
way of life being wiped out Catherine
soy Al Jazeera the dab in northeastern
Kenya